the reactions and synthesis methods
developed have made organic synthesis
much easier do you think that catalyzed
organic synthesis reactions play an
important role in solving the energy
crisis faced by the world I think at the
moment that not so direct relation with
energy crisis but of course organic she
is very important chemistry but in the
near future we can the considers such a
reaction even in energy crisis for
example you know carbon dioxide is a
very terrible the chemicals but in the
near future from the carbon dioxide if
we can the the produce that the carbon
compound that should be very important
for such an energy crisis